Well, if you actually tried this, you will see that you get 434. That's a
little unfortunate. The reason here is if you remember that 4.35 times 100
because of round off was 434.99 something. And the 0.99 something is the
fractional part, and that was thrown away to get this integer. To really do
this right in Java, you have to use a pretty arcane formula that's in fact so
arcane that I have to look it up. You use a mathematical function called round
that gets you the closest integer. So, 4.35 times 100 may be 434.999. But the
closest integer to that is 435. And then, for reasons that are too depressing
to have to get into, you still have to cast that into int. We have a fact sheet
that you can consult if you actually run into this situation. The round
function here is one example of a mathematical function. There's a bunch of
them, and we'll take them up soon, but first let's do another programming
exercise.